so I've got a couple of leg
get-to-know-you type games for you guys
today so our viewers don't get to know
you first off so I don't have to make
you all do the roll call right now if
you had the opportunity to role swap
with anyone on the show who would you
pick and why I'd like to know how come I
know you just seems like a such a cool
character to play a very complex
character but Peters Peters carriage are
oh yeah he's just so much fun he's just
like it's quite stupid really enjoy his
skills and the way he moves and I like
it a lot I like to play oh no she's just
a badass she's just like oh yeah exactly
to have fighting skills we saw the
trailer last night and there's this long
Tartabull has sickening like yeah really
good ending yeah I almost don't want you
to pick another role I know I feel like
I know the answer to this question now
but of the four of you who is most like
their character my money yeah he's he
didn'r I've only seen two episodes but
it seems to be he's earning his journey
in their territory
yes I believe it's making its way up so
if you guys had the opportunity to learn
more about a crew members job on this
show who would you pick and why yeah
Larry's Larry Pressler Pecha
yeah I'm really into cinematography
cameras definitely definitely camera
team I always be used word in senior
yeah oh shut up
well they were just few there were old
anamorphic lenses yeah
so they were Gable yeah it's like like a
really big likely icon every why it's
pretty impressive it was like the idea
that you were like watching the Western
because over any widescreen if all four
of you gotten a swordfight right now who
would win Holden way as characters as
people that's people no no going back up
this means again I've seen the first two
episodes I don't give me the benefit of
the doubt but no fake I got some would
you rather questions for you guys
would you rather work with a real animal
or a CG creature yeah no definitely G I
killed a bird on this one I'm really
happy with CT yeah how are you guys with
the horseback riding bad then thought
would it be oh yeah not that they taught
us pretty well yeah I read it so like
who would who would win in a horse race
I guess me oh the best was I have
flick-flick Mikey B horse he is
incredible he's like a beast okay flip -
oh wait oh wait so there's flit who are
the other horses so because we're in New
Zealand I think our German as like the
character horse yeah so Manny does like
to carry these two I just have something
out of myself we can go I'm standing by
what he's saying that he can still get
pretty fast both awesome yeah but you
both of you if I can control them
no we don't know I just sent back Felix
yeah
I want weeks to post like b-roll so I
could watch some behind the scenes yeah
I love that I love that who would you
guys rather have to eat a lot in a scene
or run a lot in a scene oh that's
actually good that's a troubling one I'd
like to do one and then the other so
like eat a lot in the first scene in
your Chi they go from run cheese yea I
would choose I actually spend a film
like one entire week of running in the
summer did you yeah it was five days of
just running with a car behind me I run
it pretty scary it is if I would fall
eating I have experience with running I
think I have like I had like 20 omelets
one day honestly like that's a season no
no I wish I was shooting something I see
so they're seeing scene when it's being
omelet my mum and I didn't take into
account that the camera wasn't on me
little Nina and I didn't take an
accountant that like I'm gonna be so
much more forward when Konya cameras
gonna carry only eat this on there and
honestly there is no a spit bucket for
head no no no favors oh yeah after being
on this I didn't I didn't how about you
anything I just had almost all day
this isn't would you rather but if you
guys could go back to the beginning of
your very first role ever what piece of
advice would you give yourself like was
there any kind of like a question that
you thought was a silly question that
you were afraid to ask when you got your
first favorite question if it comes into
my head like are you stupid
yeah yeah so if you can give yourself
yeah yeah well I think you had it all
week where I am like just stop buying
ground like just don't overthink it all
definite that definitely go everything
and it's really easy to be very so
school yeah yes I think yeah just give
yourself less of a hard time yeah there
was a hard you say oh I wish I could
productive that 30 no you didn't care
was just one great amusement park you
know everything was just fun I didn't
care you know you're like secure the
entire time feel like that advice
applies to every industry yeah I don't
what you do the factor would you rather
would you rather have to fake sneeze or
fake bomb adenosine think oh that's that
foam that's another one that trips you
up a little yeah well it won't be easy a
fake moment do you think you did put
liquid in your mouth you know something
you can also have a cue that's fine
God faintly the convincing fake sneeze
is what gets me crazy though I do not
know I'm gonna woman would you rather
mess up every single take yourself or if
someone else mess up your best take have
I say again so someone mess up like take
someone mess up you're just your best
take or you'd be the one to mess up
everybody else's takes I don't who who
was the one to mess up the most takes on
this show probably man phone Ivica is
really smooth like in like that fighting
season horseback riding scenes he's
meant to be really scared like nervous
but he's just having so much fun yeah
yeah man you meant to be upset yeah
alright that I feel like that's the best
possible reason to be has the best
reasons yes who was the one who was most
likely to go to craft service and spill
something on their wardrobe is them he's
not here Islam I said okay Zalman phase
I mentally do that yeah only because go
frequently he's at the craft services
that he gets a coffee literally in
between every single tea and I feel like
he would definitely
the lone self yeah but I spoke orange
juice all over my costume one guy does
that any time any time if you like this
hit or miss whether or not that leaves a
mark yeah going off of that though would
you rather work on a set with no food or
no caffeine no campaigns them know
there's a point Dean you got to stay
yourself
no no that's the right answer
why just caffeine you can live on your
damn caffeine it might not be the choice